[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing severus snape voldemort and
horcruxes more specifically we're going
to be discussing whether or not snape
was aware of the fact that voldemort had
created horcruxes voldemort's key to
immortality
voldemort's creation of horcruxes which
are arguably one of the darkest and most
twisted forms of magic started off with
just a misguided young boy unsure of his
place in the world tom riddle was an
orphan abandoned by his mother at wool's
orphanage before he ever got a chance to
know her his existence was a tragedy and
the only reason that he was ever birthed
at all was because his mother had used a
love potion on his father when the
effects of the love potion wore off tom
middle senior immediately left murapi
and this meant that tom riddle started
off his life with nothing but
abandonment after years at the orphanage
dumbledore eventually discovered the
young riddle and brought him to the
world's finest magical school while a
student at hogwarts riddle was very
impressive and he expressed an
unparalleled ability to learn he
constantly asked questions and he didn't
want to leave any stoner unturned when
it came to the wizarding world there is
one particular branch of magic however
that captivated riddle and it's a form
of magic that he certainly should have
never discovered that magic involves
horcruxes objects in which dark witches
or wizards have imbued part of their
soul the ultimate purpose of creating a
horcrux is to achieve immortality
however the truly sinister component of
creating horcrux is that in order to
produce one you must murder someone as
he grew older and as he learned more
about horcruxes he began to create them
for himself and eventually he had many
being one of only two known wizards to
have created them at one point in time
severus snape was a full-fledged death
eater and devoted servant of the dark
lord
disgusted with the actions of the
quote-unquote good guys and fueled by
the torment that he'd endured for much
of his upbringing snape turned to the
dark side and became one of voldemort's
right-hand men in fact it was snape
himself that overheard sybil trolloni
discussing the fabled prophecy and snape
2 who relayed the message to voldemort
the two were close snape trusted
voldemort and voldemort trusted snape
but that all changed when lily evans
life was in danger given that snape was
in voldemort's inner circle for so many
years and that he had formed such a
close bond with him i always wondered
was snape aware of voldemort's horcraxes
and if not why wasn't he snape was a
bonafide magical genius and he knew more
about magic than almost every other
wizard in the wizarding world having
gone down the rabbit hole of both sides
of the wizarding spectrum good and bad
not only that but he was a master
legilimens a master of the mind
he knew exactly how to read people how
to analyze their behaviors and patterns
how could he have missed powerful dark
magic at play the truth is snape didn't
know about voldemort horcruxes but it's
not because he wasn't observant or
because he did anything wrong he simply
missed them because he didn't know what
they were horcruxes are one of the
darkest forms of magic and the number of
witches wizards aware of their existence
is infinitesimal the only reason that
tom riddle was lucky enough to have
learned more about them is because horus
loghorn was his teacher who just so
happened to have some info about them in
fact slughorn's inadvertent guidance was
undoubtedly instrumental in voldemort's
rise to power though snape had delved
deep into the dark guards horcruxes
aren't exactly a common topic even in
the realm of dark magic that's how taboo
the subject is when hermione searches
for the books in the restricted section
none of them give details on horcruxes
and only one of them even mentioned
horcruxes i haven't found one single
explanation of what horcruxes do she
told him not a single one i've been
right through the restricted section and
even in the most horrible books where
they tell you how to brew the most
gruesome potions nothing all i could
find was this in the introduction to
magic most evil listen of the horcrux
wickedest of magical inventions we shall
not speak nor give direction
i mean why mention it then she said
impatiently slamming the old book shut
it let out a ghostly whale oh shut up
she snapped stuffing it back into her
bag
furthermore dumbledore himself expressed
that he didn't believe the existence of
horcruxes to be known by any of the
death eaters some of which may have
known more about dark magic specifically
than snape then you told me two years
later that on the night that voldemort
returned to his body he made a most
illuminating and alarming statement to
his death eaters i who have gone further
than anybody along the path that leads
to immortality that was what you told me
he said further than anybody and i
thought i knew what that meant though
the death eaters did not he was
referring to his horcruxes horcruxes in
the plural harry which i do not believe
any other wizard has ever had it was an
area of magic that was generally unknown
entirely uncharted even lucius malfoy a
dark wizard that dove into some of the
darkest forms of magic and boasted about
it knew nothing of voldemort's horcruxes
he was a magical object expert yet he
was unable to recognize the properties
of a certain magical object in his
possession tom riddle's diary of course
lucius did not know what the diary
really was i understand that voldemort
had told him the diary would cause the
chamber of secrets to reopen because it
was cleverly enchanted had lucius known
he held a portion of his master's soul
in his hands he would undoubtedly have
treated it with more reverence but
instead he went ahead and carried out
the old plan for his own ends by
planting the diary upon arthur weasley's
daughter he hoped to discredit arthur
have me thrown out of hogwarts and get
rid of a highly incriminating object in
one stroke furthermore it makes perfect
sense that voldemort would avoid
mentioning horcruxes altogether why
would he reveal any kind of information
about the objects that ensured he
remained immortal discussing them would
only prompt curiosity and in turn lead
to further investigation which would
jeopardize his position as much as snape
was an all-knowing tactician that you
couldn't get anything past we have to
remember that so was voldemort he didn't
become one of the most powerful dark
wizards to have ever lived by accident
he like snape was fueled by a childhood
full of abandonment and strife allowing
him to dive into magic driven and
undistracted motivated additionally the
timing at which both voldemort and snape
attended hogwarts is of utmost
importance here's the thing the majority
of the knowledge that voldemort
initially gathered on horcruxes did
actually come from the hogwarts library
however we also know that by the time
harry goes to hogwarts there are no
books to be found that broach the topic
so where did these books go we need to
remember that when tom riddle started at
hogwarts dumbledore was still just a
professor which meant that he was not
yet in charge of the school however
dumbledore did eventually become
headmaster and it was at this point that
he removed all books from the hogwarts
library mentioning horcruxes fully aware
of the destruction that they can bring
in the wrong hands well said hermione
i've been researching that
how asked harry i didn't think there
were any books on horcruxes in the
library there weren't said hermione who
had turned pink dumbledore removed them
all but he he didn't destroy them in
short though snape had the same affinity
for learning as voldemort he didn't have
access to the same dark materials
growing up which meant that he never
learned of the horcrux wickedest of
magical inventions
and that's it for this video did you
guys ever think about this let me know
in the comment section below until next
time there is plenty to be learned even
from a bad teacher what not to do how
not to be
you